well I do think the larger questions are
questions of climate change which will
affect many other things I mean climate
change will affect poverty because
unfortunately the places that are
already the hardest hit are going to
suffer more droughts the place is least
capable of coping with dramatic climatic
change are the places they're going to
be the hardest hit it'll create refugee
flows which has consequences for
security it will create more failed
States which has consequences also for
security so I start with climate change
as being something that affects the
globe and you would think what is the
the old imagery that if the world was
ever attacked you know by invaders from
outer space we'd all draw together
there's plenty of movies that have tried
to to be built around that kind of a
theme but climate change is not an
external threat it's an internal one and
it requires a it's going to affect
everything so number one I would say
climate change which also as I said it
affects poverty it affects health and
when I look at the big issues I think
they start with that
well I think you can't understand Israel
without understanding the Holocaust the
Holocaust is the seminal event in Jewish
history at least the seminal tragedy in
Jewish history and you have the birth of
a nation state that emerges out of that
the Zionist movement was creating the
basis for a state before that but the
Holocaust that is a transforming reality
so Israel emerges but it has that as its
its most important element of history
and historical identity and the
significance of that is for Israelis the
worst can happen it's not it's not there
imagining or conjuring up what are false
kinds of threats the worst can happen so
in terms of affecting the Israeli
outlook number one you start with the
premise that the worst can happen
because of the Holocaust number two
you're dealing with the reality that all
your neighbors for the first you know at
least until nineteen seventy seven when
I more thought came to Israel so for
almost 30 years 29 years of your
existence as a state all of your
neighbors rejected you rejected your
existence rejected your legitimacy and
even today it's still hard you're hard
put to say even when the Arab world is
prepared to say we're prepared to live
with you there certainly aren't signs of
a kind of reconciliation a kind of
genuine warmth the peace Israel has the
piece of Israel has with Egypt is a very
cold piece the piece it has with Jordan
is also certainly not a particularly
warm piece and there may be all sorts of
reasons from the standpoint of the Arab
world and particularly the Palestinians
why that's the case but if you're
looking at it from the standpoint of the
Israelis they live in a world where
their neighborhood has never really
accepted them and where the worst can
happen and where they're constantly
dealing with a kind of rejection which
also plays out in terms of forms of
Terror where terrorist outrages can be
conducted and from again from the
Israeli standpoint the neighbor is even
when they condemn certain acts of terror
it's all kind of
slogan istic it doesn't seem
particularly genuine so when the when
the Arab League initiative was adopted
in 2002 by the Arab League a resolution
that said that in return for Israel with
drawings to June 467 lines there would
be the establishment of full diplomatic
relations with Israel this came in a
resolution adopted in Beirut and the
very next day there's a park hotel
bombing on the first night of Passover
and nobody who's at this Arab League
meeting where this resolution has been
adopted is prepared to condemn it so the
message of the Israelis is will the
words or one thing the realities of
something else so the whole Israeli
mindset is governed by a perception of
not really being accepted where terror
is seen it against you seen as being
legitimate and where security becomes a
preoccupation and you have to do it
because you can't rely upon anybody else
1967 is a war where the Israelis have
commitments from the Eisenhower
administration which the Johnson
administration doesn't fulfill and it
reminds the Israelis okay we're on our
own then of course when they win in a
dramatic way then there's a feeling not
only well are we on our own but that's
okay because we can handle it so there's
a profound sense of self-reliance but
it's also a function of feeling
ultimately you can't count on anybody
else and we always have to be the ones
who rely upon ourselves there's a
preoccupation with security because of
that whole context I described and
security becomes a kind of sinequan on
for how to see the world now as Israel
develops and it becomes actually quite I
think quite effective in terms of its
development economically you look at it
now it's 140 billion dollar economy
Dwarfs all of its neighbors so it's very
successful and more and more of the
Israelis see themselves connected to the
world because of the global economy and
their success in competing in the global
economy so there's a there's an
interesting duality that's emerging the
sense of being on your own the sense of
being
redwood security somehow you have this
other reality where the world is shrunk
and economically speaking you're an
important part of it and so there's
there's an evolution taking place
although pretty hard to dismiss the
preoccupation with security
the in the Arab mind said there was a
sense of fundamental grievance the land
was Palestinian and it was taken from
them and they weren't prepared to accept
that Israel had a right to be there
especially if they were seen as being
usurpers and taking the place of the
Palestinians and this was seen as an
outside force that came in and took the
land and the land had a kind of sacred
quality so from the Arab standpoint
there was a sense of this kind of
outside interloper usurper and there was
a fundamental injustice a fundamental
wrong and the land was taken from the
Palestinians so you wouldn't accept the
Israelis now that was a what I would
describe as a kind of ethos that existed
in the Arab world it was also exploited
because there were those who were
leaders who sought to use that to
mobilize support for themselves both
internally and in competition with their
neighbors and it wasn't really that they
cared so much about the Palestinians as
much as they care to use it as an issue
for political purposes and for
legitimating purposes since they most of
them had seized power they'd hadn't they
hadn't won power in the basis of the
consent of the government of the
governed they didn't really have a
legitimate basis for power so they had
to seek some other legitimizing element
and using the Palestine issue became a
legitimizing element so there is both a
genuine reality of injustice and a
grievance but there's also the
exploitation of this for internal
legitimizing purposes
well I think there's I guess there's two
points I would make the first point is
that israel needs to show that israel is
prepared to take very far-reaching steps
now it has a pretty strong basis in
which to say this because first it did
withdraw from all the Sinai for peace
with Egypt it unilaterally withdrew from
Lebanon and unilaterally withdrew from
gaza which is a way to say look we we
are not interested in taking others land
and they should make it clear were
prepared to work out a deal you know the
kind of deal we put on the table in the
year 2000 would have provided for Israel
holding about five percent of the West
Bank for settlement blocs but swapping
territory for as a kind of compensation
there was going to be territorial and
non-territorial compensation I think
would be good for Israel to sort of lay
out we're prepared to do that we're
prepared to take these steps but one
thing we've learned is we can't take
only unilateral steps unilateral steps
are seen as a sign of weakness
unilateral steps don't require
responsibility on anybody else's part
peace is a function of mutual
responsibility not the responsibility
only at one side so is really think
needs to frame issues I talked about
statecraft well statecraft for the
Israelis is frame issues very
differently make it clear how far you're
prepared to go but make it clear there
has to be responsibility on the other
side to it can only be Israel and
there's going to be no more unilateral
withdrawals because you actually don't
strengthen the hand of those who are
sure are prepared to coexist in lateral
withdrawals end up strengthening the
hand of those who reject you so I think
Israel has to frame issues differently
make it clear of hearts prepared to go
talk about a readiness for not only
peace agreements but peace agreements
based on on mutual responsibility not
only the responsibility of one side
secondly I think these raleys me again
to focus on what's important Israel one
of the reasons you had akadema party
emerged and create be created by Prime
Minister schron was because in the end
he understood that Israel couldn't stay
in the territories the reason he would
true from Gaza and was prepared for
further disengagement from the West Bank
was because of the demographic issue
Israel has to be remained true to itself
it is a Jewish Democratic state if it
stays and the territory is given the
demographic trends it loses it has to
make a choice either it could be Jewish
or Democratic but it can't be both if it
stays in the territories given the
demographic trends that's ultimately
what the sure own understanding was it
was understood much more clearly and
articulated expressly by Prime Minister
Rabine who in effect believed in
partition he wanted to reach it either
through agreement or through separation
the point about separation has to be
that if Israel is going to get out of
the territories from a settlement
standpoint unless there's responsibility
assumed on the other side it doesn't get
out from a military standpoint the
military presence is there so long as no
one is prepared to assume responsibility
on the other side you know not for one
day since Israel got out of Gaza did
rocket stop not for one day if they got
out of the west bank tomorrow same thing
would happen only the difference is West
Bank is contiguous to all of Israel in a
way that means that every Israeli
community would be subject to vulnerable
to rocket attack so is really needs to
frame issues differently it needs to
position itself differently so it can
sustain itself as a Jewish Democratic
state it means it will have to disengage
from the West Bank but how it disengages
will be a function of whether or not in
fact there's a readiness for
Palestinians to be able in fact to
fulfill their responsibilities and if
not the disengagement will be of
settlements not of the military
well I think they fundamentally meet on
the desire for peace because i think
it's israel needs peace for itself not
as a favor to the United States the
United States favors peace because it's
right and because it makes it easier for
us to have good relations with Israelis
and Arabs so there's a convergence there
now sometimes there's a divergence in
that sometimes the u.s. is is more
prepared to push farther than the
Israelis think that their position and
security can afford as well as the way
they look at their neighbors and their
concerns about how the neighbors may
miss read some of the moves so there's
that's one area where there's a
potential diversions there's a
convergence also I think in terms of
also both being threatened by radical
Islam both of us are I think targets of
the radical Islamists we're seen as
being connected and will always be seen
as being connected and that creates also
a powerful sense of convergence where
there's a potential for divergences
because the u.s. is so sensitive to
wanting to have a certain kind of
position in the Middle East you know
sometimes it is more concerned about its
relationship with the Arab world even if
it would come at some cost to its
relationship with Israel so I think
that's an area of some potential tension
but even here we're in a world now where
many in the Arab world recognize the
radical Islamists are as much a threat
to them as they are to anyone else so
there could be a natural convergence
between all of us between the what I
would say the those moderate Arab states
the Israelis in the United States the
competition with the radical Islamists
may lead to different prescriptions for
how to do it the some of the Arab states
will say gee we need the Palestinian
monkey off our back and then we can do
much more with the Israelis and the way
they would get the monkey off the back
is basically have Israel concede
anything and from their standpoint there
is no concession that's two large from
the Israeli standpoint obviously a
concession that threatens the viability
of state is too large so you know that's
where somehow the US has to find a
medium of balance that's one of the
things that a mediator has to do so I
think there's much more where we have
convergences with the Israelis certainly
in terms of values we have a fundamental
convergence with the Israelis in terms
of cooperating on issues military kinds
of issues or intelligence kinds of
issues we have enormous convergence with
the Israelis and I think in terms of
wanting peace and even the competition
with the radical Islamists a struggled
radicalism is we have great deal of
convergence it's where we we get into
those points where the Arab sets of
interests are seen as somehow in tension
especially because we're trying to
maintain certain kinds of relations with
them they have views of what it will
take to deal with the threats to all of
us that might not converge exactly with
the way the Israelis see those threats
I don't think we have to be I think that
in the case of the Iranians the whole
Iranian leadership and elite wants
nuclear weapons but not all of them
wanted at any price and the again
statecraft is governed by recognizing
the areas where those whose behavior
want to change at vulnerabilities and
focusing on how you can play on those
vulnerabilities the Iranian
vulnerabilities are acute in the
economic area so the challenge is to
find the right set of pressures on them
economically to get them to realize that
the price is going to be too high as
they measure price not as we might but
then at the same time when you
concentrate their minds this too is the
sssh craft when you concentrate their
minds on what they stand to lose if the
only thing out come they think is going
to be one of humiliation then they're
not going to concede so you at the same
time you concentrate their mind you've
got to offer them a pathway there has to
be a door that they can walk through
where they can have an outcome that's an
acceptable outcome that's a dignified
outcome that in the end allows them to
say alright we've achieved something
that's important for us and the rest of
the world is able to say okay look there
they're not going to be a nuclear weapon
state so I believe it's possible to find
that outcome but I also think that we're
beginning to run out of time
well I think the one thing I would like
to see changed is the kind of poisonous
atmosphere that everything's seen in
zero-sum terms we've lost kind of the
capacity to create areas of consensus
that Democrats and Republicans basically
can agree on and everything seems to be
seems to have fallen victim to a kind of
polarization and I think we have to we
have to end the polarization Democrats
and Republicans have different
philosophies different identities that's
fine that's part of what debates are
about but there's a lot of areas where
there should be commonalities and where
there are big issues you ought to be
able to forge commonalities we ought to
be able to forge a common approach and
climate change we ought to be able to
afford what is going to be a common
approach on Iraq we have be able to
afford what will be a common approach on
health care these are big priorities
where we have to deal with fundamental
challenges now to the country when
you're dealing with fundamental
challenges there ought to be enough
common ground that you you reach
understandings and I think it's we've
found certainly in the last almost seven
years now that the polarization has
become so acute that it's pretty hard to
do the kinds of things where otherwise
you know you should you should be able
to find that consensus I look at myself
I had senior positions political
appointee positions and Republican and
Democratic administrations alike that's
unthinkable of washing today that's
change we should be able to go back to
the point where you can have people who
are seen as being sufficiently
professional that are in political
appointees regardless of their political
identification and that's that we've
lost
you know at a certain level it there are
so many claims they make that are so
ludicrous that are so divorced from
reality that you're almost tended to
dismiss it because they create an
illusion that they have based it on
reality but it's totally divorced from
reality they don't have a fact-based
approach they have an ideologically
driven approach they may criticize the
the Bush administration and I do as well
for an ideologically driven set of
assessments and an ideological driven
policy but there's an opposite policy
that is also ideologically driven and
the facts and reality never intrude they
make a major case that it was the
Israeli Lobby that basically drove us
into war the prime decision that drove
us into war in Iraq well the Israeli
Lobby was far more preoccupied with Iran
than they were with Iraq I mean if
President Bush isn't president we don't
go to war in Iraq if if Vice President
Gore becomes president in the year 2000
even though he's the one with a long
history of very close ties to the quote
Israeli Lobby we don't go to war in Iraq
so what's decisive here was that the
Israeli Lobby or who was president they
say Israeli Lobby that is that is a
reason we never opposed Israeli
settlement activity she's not true I
mean the fact that matter is our
approach on settlements could have been
much harder than it was was it because
of Israeli Lobby wasn't no in our case
in the Clinton administration I can tell
you we had Prime Minister being say to
us I'm going to change things on
settlement activity but I can't go as
far as you might want because the fact
is I'm going to take big steps and I
need the political space to do it and
the political traffic won't bear my
taking on too much at one time so
basically we cut him some slack on that
now the fact that he was assassinated by
someone who came out of the religious
National settler movement suggests that
maybe he knew what he was talking about
a hood Barack said to us I'm going to
withdraw from almost all the territory
i'm going to settle the whole conflict
palestine's will have a state now don't
push me prematurely on the settlement
issue because you'll undercut the
political strength I need to take those
big decisions you can disagree with our
judgment but those are the reasons we
made it
not because the Israeli Lobby was asking
us to do it I said when I was a
negotiator there's never a single
decision we made because he's rayleigh
lobby wanted us to do it and there's
never a single decision we didn't make
because they didn't want us to do it so
it isn't to say is there is there and a
lobby for Israel you bet are they
effective yes are they decisive when it
comes to the executive branch absolutely
not I've heard I had one exchange with
Steven wold where he said where he
quoted because this is what they do they
quote political leaders like the
President Clinton and Newt Gingrich
saying how strong a pact is well it made
these statements when they were giving
speeches at AIPAC now how often the
political leaders go to any lobbying
group and say gee you're not strong
you're not effective but this is what
they cite is a kind of proof that's why
I say there's a kind of ludicrous
quality